la gráfica de ye igual a un medio
elevado a la x se muestra abajo y aquí
tenemos la gráfica de esta función
verdad un medio elevado a la equis y
vemos que en efecto es una gráfica de
una función exponencial verdad nos
preguntan cuál de las siguientes es la
gráfica de ye igual a un medio elevado a
la 3 menos x menos 2 y por supuesto aquí
están las cuatro opciones que nos dan
pero antes de ver estas cuatro opciones
con detalle a mí me gustaría que
pensemos en cómo se vería esta función
si es que la transformamos verdad ya que
como puedes ver esta función de aquí es
en esencia una transformación de esta
función original entonces la gráfica
debería verse como una transformación
también de esta gráfica original
entonces la pregunta es cómo vamos a
transformar esta función entonces vamos
a ir describiendo cómo es que podemos
transformarla por ejemplo aquí primero
tendríamos que hacer un medio elevado a
la menos x verdad
aquí está menos x y luego trasladarla o
transformarla a 3x y luego restarle 2
entonces veamos primero qué pasaría con
ye igual a un medio elevado a la menos x
muy bien entonces pensaremos en ye igual
a un medio elevado a la menos x y
esencialmente cuando cambiamos nuestra
variable independiente que en este caso
es x x menos x lo que estamos haciendo
es reflejar la gráfica de la función con
respecto al eje vertical es decir al eje
de verdad entonces más o menos esto se
vería como un exponencial pero que ahora
crece hacia el lado derecho verdad
entonces por ejemplo veamos algunos
valores aquí digamos cuando x es igual a
0 un medio a la menos 0 sigue siendo 1
entonces pasará justo por este valor
también verdad lo cual tiene sentido
porque está justo sobre nuestro
a partir del cual vamos a reflejar
verdad qué pasaría si por ejemplo x
fuera digamos el 2 por ejemplo qué
pasaría si x fuera 2 verdad entonces si
x fuera 2 tendríamos un medio de un
medio elevado a la menos 2 o lo que es
lo mismo 2 elevado a la 2 que es 4
verdad entonces tendríamos este valor de
aquí entonces por ejemplo si x fuera 3
tendríamos
si tendríamos un medio elevado a la
menos 3 verdad pero un medio elevado a
la menos 3 sería 2 elevada a la 3 que
sería 8 verdad entonces más o menos esto
se vería algo así tendríamos una gráfica
que se vería más o menos así y por
supuesto cuando x se haga muy negativo
verdad tendríamos un medio elevado a un
número muy muy muy grande pero como un
medio es más chico que 1 esto se
apachurra en 0 verdad entonces tendremos
una sin tota en 0 y más o menos se ve
así la gráfica de esta función ahora
nosotros tenemos ya igual a un medio
elevado a la 3 - x menos 2 pensemos
ahora antes que pasa con e igual a un
medio elevado a la 3 - x
entonces cuando tenemos una expresión
digamos parecida pero en donde estamos
sumando digamos una constante a donde
tenemos nuestro exponente lo que estaba
ocurriendo es que esta gráfica se está
trasladando verdad entonces por ejemplo
veamos algunos valores veamos algunos
valores por ejemplo para que el valor de
x este exponente ahora será 0 verdad
antes era para x igual a 0 y por eso es
que cruzaba aquí el eje verdad pero para
que el valor de x ahora este exponente
será 0 pues ahora el exponente será cero
cuando x sea igual a 3 entonces cuando x
es igual a 3 tendremos este punto de
aquí verdad este punto de aquí ahora
bien por ejemplo para que el valor de x
esto tiene el valor de menos 1 por
ejemplo entonces 3 menos 4 nos da menos
1 y un medio a la menos 1
2 verdad entonces cuando x es igual a 4
la función vale 2 entonces cómo podemos
ver esta gráfica lo único que está
haciendo es trasladarse 3 unidades a la
derecha así que toda esta gráfica verdad
se verá justamente
digamos trasladada tres unidades a la
derecha verdad es simplemente la gráfica
azul trasladada a tres unidades a la
derecha y por supuesto mi dibujo no es
muy preciso verdad pero más o menos nos
da una idea de qué es lo que está
ocurriendo y por supuesto tendrá la
misma asiento está muy bien entonces
ahora con esto ya podemos ver qué ocurre
con la función que nos interesa igual a
un medio elevado a la 3 - x menos 2 y
esencialmente lo que está haciendo el
menos 2 es desplazar toda nuestra
gráfica que ya habíamos construido pero
dos unidades hacia abajo verdad entonces
por ejemplo si nuestra cinta está estaba
en de igual a cero verdad de igual a
cero ahora la sin tota se encontrará en
de igual a menos 2 así que voy a ponerla
por aquí esta será nuestra así en total
por ejemplo si en x igual a 3 valía 1
verdad como ahora estamos trasladando 2
abajo ahora vale menos 1 como en x igual
a 4 valía 2 y estamos trasladando 2
abajo ahora vale 0 verdad entonces con
estos puntos ya más o menos podemos
esbozar la gráfica que le corresponde
que es exactamente la que teníamos en
rosa pero está trasladada dos unidades
hacia abajo verdad y por supuesto aquí
tenemos nuestra cinta verdad más o menos
así se ve la gráfica entonces con esto
ya podemos analizar nuestras opciones
que tenemos verdad por ejemplo qué
pasaría con la opción a bueno la opción
a tenemos que descartarla porque si nos
damos cuenta de hecho lo voy a hacer con
un color más oscuro si nos damos cuenta
ésta crece hacia el lado izquierdo
cuando nuestra gráfica azul crece hacia
el lado derecho entonces ésta no puede
ser verdad lo mismo
digamos tiene el mismo problema la
opción b porque ésta crece
asintóticamente hacia
digamos hacia la cinta está justamente y
no es así verdad para aproximarnos a la
cinta es para x muy negativo entonces
esta opción no va veamos qué ocurre con
la opción c bueno está más o menos tiene
la geometría que estábamos buscando
verdad que hacia atrás se aproxima la
cinta y crezca hacia la derecha y la
cinta está de hecho se encuentra en
igual a menos 2 verdad más o menos aquí
se ve la 5ta entonces ésta puede ser una
buena opción y por ejemplo podemos
descartar la opción de verdad porque en
efecto ésta no crece cuando x tiende
digamos a valores cada vez más y más
grandes entonces la opción correcta para
este ejercicio es la opción c y también
hay otra manera de resolver este
problema a mí en realidad me gusta mucho
hacerlo de esta forma porque se aprecia
muy bien cómo es que se va transformando
la gráfica pero por ejemplo podríamos
haber pensado algo de este estilo por
ejemplo tengo ye igual a un medio a la 3
menos x y luego restamos
entonces podemos analizar qué pasa con
este término cuando x es muy negativo
cuando x es muy negativo entonces este
exponente se hace cada vez más grande
pero además se hace positivo verdad
crece muchísimo y un medio elevado a un
exponente muy grande pues tiende a cero
verdad porque un medio es un número más
chico que uno y a medida que uno vea va
aumentando el exponente esto se hace un
número cada vez más pequeño y luego si
restamos dos pues nos aproximaremos
hacia menos dos de ahí la idea de
nuestra a sin tota y después podríamos
haber construido por ejemplo una tablita
y ver dos valores verdad por ejemplo
aquí podríamos poner x podríamos poner
ye
poner bien nuestra tabla aquí está xy
aquí está y entonces cuando x tiende a
menos infinito dijimos que ya se
aproxima a menos 2
ahora cuando x por ejemplo démosle el
valor de 3 cuando x es igual a 3
entonces 3 menos 13 0 un medio a la cero
es uno y uno menos dos nos da menos uno
ahora bien por ejemplo digamos que x es
igual a 43 menos 4 es menos uno un medio
a la menos uno es 2 y si luego le
restamos 2 nos da 0 entonces justamente
son estos dos puntos aquí está x igual a
3 nos da menos 1 y x igual a 4 nos da 0
verdad ahí tenemos nuestros dos puntos y
con esto ya podríamos verificar que la
opción c es la respuesta correcta verdad
entonces espero que de verdad hayas
disfrutado este ejercicio